we are in problem 15 15.
the store charges 28 for a type of
sweater 28
for a sweater this price is 40 percent
more than it costs to store to buy
one of these sweaters
so
28 dollars is 40 percent more than what
it costs
so that equals the cost plus
40 percent of the cost
right
point four is the same thing as forty
percent right it's the cost plus forty
percent of cost that's what forty
percent war means another way you can
kind of immediately say well that's just
the same thing as one point four times
the cost and that's kind of shorthand um
you might immediately go to this step
1.4 times cost okay let's see what it
says at the end of season sale store
employees can purchase any remaining
sweaters at 30 percent
off the store's cost so the sale price
let me call that s
is equal to the cost
minus 0.3 times the cost right 30
off of the cost this is 30 of the cost
you take that off of the original cost
and that is equal to of course 0.7 times
the cost right this is the sale price is
0.7 times the cost
how much would it cost an employee to
purchase a sweater of this type at this
sale
all right so let's see so how much would
it cost so we could figure out what the
cost is from this equation we have 28
is equal to 1.4
times the cost
cost is equal to 28
divided by 1.4 i just divide both sides
by one before i switched them around to
do
see 28 by 4 divided by 14 would be 2
right but 28 divided by 1.4 is 20.
all right so that makes sense and you
could go the other way you know 40 more
than
forty percent of twenty is eight and you
add eight to twenty you get twenty eight
so that's right the cost is twenty
dollars and now the sale is point seven
times the cost so sale
is equal to point seven times the cost
and that equals what twenty times 0.7
is
14 dollars
right because 20 times 7 is 140 you have
one decimal place 14
so that is choice b
next problem
problem 16.
then we're done with this section
16.
and rectangle abcd let me draw a
rectangle a b c d even though they
haven't
okay rectangle a whoops
a
b
c
d
and rectangle a b c d e is the midpoint
of b c
so let me draw e
e is the midpoint
of bc so this distance is equal to that
distance
if the area of quadril
quadral a b e d a b e d
is two-thirds what is the area of the
entire rectangle fascinating so they
they they making another quadrilateral
within this
i'll just draw it because so let me do
another color so they're saying the area
of this thing
a
b e
d
a b e d
this thing
area of that thing is two-thirds
and so they want you to figure out the
area of the whole thing and so this is
just a pure visualization problem
because what i can do is i can break up
this rectangle in a interesting way
let me do it with this brown color
if i wanted to break off this rectangle
i could break it up
into four equal triangles right
i could break it up into four equal
triangles
you see here one two three four and how
do i know they're equal because e is the
midpoint we know
we know that
this side is equal to this side because
e is the midpoint
we know that one we know that
we we know that this is equal to this
which is equal to this so we know that
these are these are all four of these
rectangles are going to be the same
now they tell us that the area of three
of this rectangle this rectangle and
this rectangle right that's a b e d they
tell us three of the rectangles
sorry three of the triangles have i've
been saying rectangles all time these
are triangles a b e a these are
triangles so they so this rectangle is
made up of four equal triangles right
we know that three of the triangles this
quadra quadrilateral
this quadrilateral here
three of the triangles i'll call them
three triangles
and we call it three times the area of
each triangle is equal to what
is equal to two-thirds
and we know that because they told us
that the area of this plus this plus
this is two-thirds this quadrilateral
is two-thirds so what's the area of each
triangle the area of each triangle is
going to be
two-thirds divided by three which is two
ninths right two thirds times one third
area of each triangle is two ninths
so what's going to be the area of this
entire of this entire rectangle well
it's going to be this area
that we just know is two-thirds
plus the area of one more triangle right
here plus the area of this triangle and
then we get the whole rectangle so plus
two-ninths
and this equals see common denominator
is nine
this becomes two-thirds becomes
six-ninths
and then you have the plus the
two-ninths
and this becomes eight ninths
and that is choice c
and we are done so this is a pure
visualization problem you just have to
see that the area they gave you was
three equal triangles and they
essentially just want you to add the
fourth onto it and figure out what the
total area is
i'll see in the next section